ladies and gentlemen
state the obvious
we me we meet with the eyes of history
upon us
and the profound questions before us
it's simple will we act
will we do what is necessary
will we seize the enormous opportunity
before us
or we or we will condemn future
generations to suffer
this
is the decade that will determine the
answer this decade
the science is clear
we only have a brief window left before
us to
raise our ambitions and
to raise to meet the task
that's rapidly narrowing
this is a decisive decade
in which we have an opportunity to prove
ourselves
we can keep the goal of limiting global
warming to just 1.5 degrees celsius
within our reach
if we come together
if we commit to doing our part
of each of our nations with
determination
and with ambition
that's what cop 26 is all about
glasgow must be the kickoff of a decade
a decade of ambition
and innovation to preserve our shared
future
climate change
is already ravaging the world we've
heard from many speakers
it's not hypothetical it's not a
hypothetical threat it's destroying
people's lives and livelihoods and doing
it every single day
it's costing our nation's
trillions of dollars
record heat and drought fueling more
widespread and more intense wildfires in
some places and crop failures and others
record flooding
and what used to be a once in a century
storms
are now happening every few years
in the past few months the united states
has experienced all of this
and every region in the world
can tell similar stories
and in an age where this pandemic is
made so painfully clear that no nation
can wallet salt wall itself offer
borderless threats
we know that none of us can escape
the worse that's yet to come
if we fail to seize this moment
but ladies and gentlemen within the
growing catastrophe
i believe there's an incredible
opportunity
not just for the united states but for
all of us
we're standing at an inflection point in
world history we have the ability to
invest in ourselves
and build an equitable clean energy
future and in the process create
millions of good paying jobs and
opportunities around the world
cleaner air for our children
more bountiful oceans
healthier forests and ecosystems for our
planet
we can create an environment
that raises the standard of living
around the world
and this is a moral imperative but it's
also an economic imperative
if we fuel
greater growth
new jobs better opportunities for all
our people
and as we see
current volatility in energy prices
rather than cast it as a reason to back
off our clean energy goals we must view
it as a call to action
high energy prices only only reinforce
the urgent need to diversify diversify
sources
double down on clean energy development
and adapt promising new clean energy
technologies so we can not only oh
over we don't remain overly reliant on
one source of power to power our
economies and our communities
it's in the self-interest of every
single nation
and this is a chance in my view to make
a generational investment
in our economic resilience
and on our workers and our communities
throughout the world
that's what we're going to do in the
united states
my bill back better framework will make
historic investments in clean energy
the most significant investment to deal
with the climate crisis
that any advanced nation has made ever
we're going to cut u.s greenhouse gas
emissions by well over a gigaton
by 2030 while making it more affordable
for consumers to save on their own
energy bills
with tax credits for things like
installing solar panels weatherizing
their homes
lowering energy prices will also deliver
cleaner air and water for our children
electrifying fleets of school buses
increasing credits for electric vehicles
and addressing
legacy pollution
it will incentivize clean energy
manufacturing building the solar panels
and the wind turbines that are growing
energy markets of the future which will
create good paying union jobs for
american workers
and something that none of us should
lose sight of
when i talk to the american people about
climate change i tell them it's about
jobs it's about workers that will lay
thousands of miles of transmission lines
of clean modern resilient power grid
the auto workers will build the next
generation of electric vehicles and
electricians who will install
a nationwide network of five hundred
thousand vehicle stations to power them
throughout my country
the engineers will design new carbon
capture systems
and the construction workers will make
them
a reality
the farmers will not only help fight
global hunger but also use the soil to
fight climate climate change
the communities that revitalize
themselves around new industries and
opportunities and because
we are
taking all these actions the united
states will be able to meet ambitious
target i said
in the leaders summit and climate back
in april reducing u.s emissions
by 50 to 52
below
2005
levels by 2030.
will demonstrate to the world the united
states is not only back at the table
but hopefully leading by the
power of our example
i know it hasn't been
the case
and that's why my administration is
working overtime
to show that our climate commitment
is action not words
on my very first day in office i took
action to return the united states to
the parish agreement
since then our administration has been
hard at work unlocking clean energy
breakthroughs to drive down the cost of
technologies that will require us to do
to achieve net zero emissions and
working with the private sector on the
next generation of technologies that
will power clean economy of the future
over the next several days the united
states will be announcing new
initiatives to demonstrate our
commitment to providing innovative
solutions across multiple sectors from
agriculture to oil and gas
to combating deforestation deforestation
to tackling hard
and to abate industries
we're planning
for both short-term sprint to
2030 that will keep 1.5 degrees celsius
in reach
and for a marathon that will take us
take us to the finish line and transform
the largest economy in the world into a
thriving innovative equitable and just
clean energy engine
of net zero for a net zero world
that's why today i'm releasing the us
long-term strategy
which presents a vision of achieving
the united states goal of net zero
emissions economy wide by no later than
2050
and
reinforces an absolutely critical nature
of taking bold action within the
decisive decade
we're also going to try to do our part
when it comes to helping the rest of the
world take action as well
we want to do more to help countries
around the world especially developing
countries accelerate their clean energy
transition
address pollution and ensure the world
we all must share a cleaner safer
healthiest planet we have an obligation
to help
in the united nations at the united
states in september i announced that my
administration is working with the
congress to quadruple our climate
finance support for developing countries
by 2024 including significant increase
in support for adaptation efforts this
commitment is made possible
to each of our collective goals of
mobilizing 100 billion dollars annually
for climate finance but mobilizing
finance and the skill necessary to meet
the incredible need
is an all hands on deck effort
as other speakers today have mentioned
governments in the private sector and
multilateral
development banks must also do their
work to go from millions to billions to
trillions the necessary effect of this
transition
today i'm also submitting a new
adaptation communication
laying out how we'll implement the
global goal of adaptation as well as
announcing our first ever contribution
to the adaptation fund
but our commitment is about more than
just financing that's a critical piece
of it we're also going to support
solutions across the board
in the lead up to this gathering the
united states joined our g7 partners to
launch a build back better world
initiative
we also reconvene the major economies
forum on energy and climate
to launch transformative actions and to
raise ambition
and together with the european union
we're launching a global methane pledge
to collectively reduce methane emissions
one of the most potent greenhouse gases
by at least 30 percent by the end of the
decade
more than 70 countries have already
signed up to support rapid reduction of
methane pollution and i encourage every
nation to sign on
it's it's the simple most effective
strategy we have to slow global warming
in the near term
my friends
if you're to recognize that a better
more hopeful future of every nation
has to do its part with ambitious
targets to keep 1.5 degrees in reach
and specific plans of how to get there
especially
the major economies
it's imperative we support developing
nations
so
they can be our partners in this effort
right now
we're still falling short
there's no more time to hang back or sit
in the fence or argue amongst ourselves
this is the challenge of our collective
lifetimes
the existential threat threat to human
existence as we know it
and every day we delay
the cost of inaction increases
so let this be the moment that we answer
history's call here in glasgow
let this be the start of a decade of
transformative action
that preserves our planet and raises the
quality of life for people everywhere
we can do this
we just have to make a choice to do it
so let's get to work and thank you those
of us
who are responsible for much of the
deforestation and all the problems we
have so far
have an overwhelming obligations of the
nations who in fact were not there have
not done it and we have to help
much more than we have thus far
god bless you all and may god save the
planet thank you